you thought we were done with more tips
and tricks nope
we're back with more stuff you still
probably don't know about breath of the
wild
side note some of these we're not going
too in depth on
so if you want separate explainers on
how some of these tricks are done
let us know and of course if you like
this series let us know with a like
we appreciate it alright onwards
did you know that ancient bows have a
special property that no other weapon
has
they have a secret armor-piercing
property
while other bows are blocked with their
shields up ancient bows pierce right
through
this is extremely useful against pesky
enemies constantly putting their guard
up
and this can be used in special
situations that will be shown later in
the video
this even works against yourself the
mighty hylian shield doesn't stand a
chance
by scaring the king towards an enemy
encampment he'll freeze up
and get harassed by the goblins
i'd suggest standing up to bullying
instead of just recording from a
distance link
wait a minute isn't the king a ghost
this doesn't make any sense
rejoice and seal patricia can give some
words of wisdom if you hand her a couple
snacks
and a couple puns as well i suggest
feeding her a couple times because she
has a couple more tips to give
the rito couple tebba and saki are
placed like this because in japanese
this is a play on words that roughly
translates to
uh chicken wings have you ever cheesed
your way to a monk before
extracting the rune before well you'll
get this message telling you to go back
[Music]
nintendo knew people were going to break
this game even before it came out
with lionel's fireballs the standard
response is to run
left or right but have you ever tried
going up
fireballs can chase you pretty high
vertically
most heavy objects in breath of the wild
make link walk fairly slowly and have
some really awkward animations
but there's an interesting glitch
nicknamed golden gauntlets that allows
you to pick up normally heavy objects
like nothing
walk around at normal speed and chuck
them with no problem
if you block a rock octorock's shot with
a large item such as a box
up close throwable items it sucks up
will ricochet off and become
miniaturized versions of themselves
the interesting part though is even
though this is obviously a glitch and is
not intended
the physics system still follows the
same rules which means the item is
actually lighter
is able to be thrown farther and has
different rolling properties
if you pay close attention you'll notice
that entering bullet time slows down
animations in the menu as well as in the
game the thunderstorm rod's current runs
slower
and the blade saw's teeth turns more
slowly
[Music]
if you burn a yiga foot soldier's bow
out of their hands they lose their bow
and have nothing left to do
except keep their distance and dance
around is that the stinky leg
near the southern oasis it's been noted
in the game's code that there's a single
random shock arrow here but nothing is
found
that's because it is up in the sky like
way up in the sky
past the skybox's limits where no one
can reach maybe one day someone will
find a way to claim it
it's been long known that lizolfos have
the capability to catch boomerangs out
of the air but did you know that
bokoblins and moblins are just as
capable of catching them as well
if you throw something in front of
enemies while disguised pick up the item
then
chase them around with it they'll want
nothing to do with you
anyone could cook in a cooking pot but
the real way to cook is to grab a couple
treasure chests
a door and make a fire underneath now
this
is some outdoor cooking
you've seen your friend hes2 before
probably many many times
but have you ever seen him run
[Music]
this is missing something there you go
have you ever seen under vilia's mask
just use rivali's gale to help you out
this doesn't feel right moving on you've
seen a fire breath lizolfo's breathe
fire
but have you seen one in the water
they'll do a similar attack to their
normal counterparts but with a fiery
twist
isilozolfo's weakness is always fire
where they'll melt immediately
but can they handle hot water nope they
even seem hesitant to get into the hot
water to attack link
you can turn link's body completely red
for a short period of time
by standing in specific shallow water
then using a multi-shot bow
over and over on a dry surface to make a
fireball link will heat up and turn
beet red you can even switch up
equipment and keep the crimson look
this is only a temporary visual glitch
though so get your pictures in while you
can
a little wilderness survival tip for you
if you ever need to make a fire and you
don't have too much anya
just pull out a bow with a fire bow
equipped then switch between the bows
very quickly
near light vegetation like grass or
plants the quick switching starts a
friction fire for you to throw wood fuel
on
this is truly a tinder fire starter
because this doesn't work on heavy wood
by itself
only on light tinder
there is a way to aim the lightning's
location other than by throwing the item
by going into bullet time and removing
all metallic equipment
then shooting a shock arrow on a
conductable surface the lightning
switches targets and aims at what you
shot
this will even target the thunderstorm
rod's projectiles
horses with gentle temperaments aren't
just calmer and easier to tame
they also don't buck the rider when you
over spur them this is mostly tied to
weak horses but there's one powerful
horse that won't throw you off when you
over spur
your trusty steed opponent what a true
friend
while this trick in particular blew up
recently it's still important to point
out that there is one other worthy of
picking up the master sword
yiga blade masters by clipping inside
the hideout or
by baiting the yiga member to the door
and then korok leafing it
they will teleport outside to you
then kite them all the way to the korok
forest which is a very
long journey and lead them to the master
sword or they will proceed to yoink the
sword with no problem
did you know that you can map pin a
flying arrow
don't know how useful that would be but
some things are just for fun
probably one of the most entertaining
things is to feed low level zoltos
if you feed them while disguised they
have special animations for catching
their prey
but sometimes their accuracy and hit
detection for catching prey is so bad
they are completely unable to catch
their meal
you may have seen whiz robes do a
special storm summoning attack before
but you can create some neat situations
with this by using a korok leaf to push
the whiz rope after the spell is cast
you can make us know in situations where
it's not normally possible
while this is obviously not a permanent
thing seeing hyrule castle or kakariko
village in the snow
is something i wish it would happen once
in a while in the game alright from here
to the next few tips involves the final
boss
so if you haven't beaten the game after
4 years looking at you
skip these next three tips the wiz robe
storm mentioned before
persists through cut scenes giving a
pretty snowy and
chilly entrance to the calamity ganon
fight
[Music]
calamity gannon has some tough armor
that deflects all attacks
except its guard is let down during
flurry rushes by using any glitched
flurry rush technique
such as perfect daruk's rush or
thunderclap rush you can attack
right through its armor if you're
interested in a compiled list of
advanced battle tech lightly explaining
these
is linked in the description below
another way to go through the armor is
by using the before mentioned ancient
bow
while it doesn't work normally if you
get into bullet time you can pierce
through ganon's armor like nothing
whenever you want now combine the two
tricks together for a fully unblockable
combo to attack
right through his pesky defenses
that's a wrap if you enjoy this series
let us know by liking this video
and check out our previous videos for
more interesting things you didn't know
and for everything else stay tuned right
here on gamespot
[Music]
you